[Esta charla contiene lenguaje obsceno. Se recomienda discreción del espectador]
Esta es la primera y la última diapositiva que
cada uno de mis 6400 estudiantes ha visto en los últimos 15 años.
No creo que se pueda construir una organización multimillonaria
a menos que se tenga claro a qué instinto u órgano se dirige.
Nuestra especie tiene una necesidad de superación.
Nuestra ventaja competitiva como especie es nuestro cerebro.
Nuestro cerebro es lo bastante robusto para hacer preguntas difíciles,
pero, desafortunadamente, carece del poder de procesamiento para responderlas,
lo que crea la necesidad de un superhumano
al que poder rezar y acudir en busca de respuestas.
¿Qué es una plegaria?
Enviar una consulta al universo,
y que con suerte haya algún tipo de intervención divina,
sin saber lo que está pasando,
de un ser omnisciente que todo lo sabe y que todo lo ve
que garantiza darnos la respuesta correcta.
"¿Va a estar bien mi hijo?"
Tenemos el planeta de las cosas,
el planeta del trabajo,
el planeta de los amigos.
Si tienen hijos,
saben que si algo sale mal con sus hijos,
todo se desmorona,
en el universo hasta el sol son los hijos.
"¿Va a estar bien mi hijo?"
"Síntomas y tratamiento de crup" en la casilla de búsqueda de Google.
Una de cada seis consultas enviadas a Google nunca se ha preguntado antes
en la historia de la humanidad.
¿Qué sacerdote, maestro, rabino, erudito, mentor o jefe tiene tanta credibilidad
que una de cada seis preguntas planteadas a esa persona
nunca se ha preguntado antes?
Google es el dios de nuestro ser humano moderno.
Imaginen su rostro y su nombre por encima de todo lo que han puesto en esa casilla,
y se darán cuenta de que confían más en Google que en cualquier entidad
en su historia.
(Risas)
Avancemos más abajo en el torso.
Otra de las cosas maravillosas sobre nuestra especie
es que no solo necesitamos ser amados, sino que necesitamos amar a los demás.
Los niños con nutrición deficiente pero que reciben mucho afecto
tienen mejor rendimiento que los niños con buena nutrición y afecto deficiente.
Sin embargo, la mejor señal de que Uds. pueden ser parte
del grupo demográfico número uno con mayor crecimiento en el mundo,
—centenarios, personas que viven hasta llegar a los tres dígitos—
se determina por tres hechos.
En orden inverso: la genética, que no es tan importante como nos gustaría creer,
así que pueden seguir tratando su cuerpo como una porquería
y pensar: "El tío Juan vivió hasta los 95, la suerte está echada".
Esto es menos importante de lo que piensan.
Número dos, el estilo de vida.
No fumen, no sean obesos y pasen controles
para no ser uno de los dos tercios con cánceres tempranos
y enfermedades cardiovasculares.
El indicador o señal número uno que los hará llegar a tres dígitos:
¿A cuántas personas aman?
Cuidar es la cámara de seguridad,
—llamamos a la cámara de seguridad de baja resolución de nuestro cerebro—
que decide si se añade valor o no.
Facebook aprovecha nuestra necesidad instintiva no solo de ser amado,
sino de amar a los demás,
principalmente a través de imágenes que crean empatía,
catalizan y refuerzan nuestras relaciones.
Continuemos nuestro viaje por el torso.
Amazon es nuestro instinto de consumo.
El instinto de aún más está integrado en nosotros.
El castigo por tener muy poco es la inanición y la desnutrición.
Abran sus armarios,
tienen entre 10 y 100 veces más de lo que necesitan.
¿Por qué?
Porque el castigo por tener muy poco es mucho mayor
que la penalización por tener demasiado.
"Más por menos" es una estrategia de negocios que nunca pasa de moda.
Es la estrategia de China,
es una estrategia de Walmart,
y ahora es la estrategia de la compañía más exitosa del mundo,
Amazon.
Obtienen más por menos para su instinto;
lo digerimos y enviamos a nuestro sistema de consumo muscular y esquelético.
Avancemos.
una vez que sabemos que sobreviviremos, el instinto básico,
nos vamos al segundo instinto más poderoso.
Es propagar y seleccionar la semilla más fuerte, más inteligente y más rápida
por toda la tierra,
o elegir la mejor semilla.
Esto no es un reloj.
No le he dado cuerda en cinco años.
Es mi vano intento de decirle a la gente,
"Si te apareas conmigo, es más probable que tus hijos sobrevivan
que si te apareas con alguien que usa un reloj Swatch".
(Risas)
La clave del negocio es aprovechar los órganos irracionales.
"Irracional", el término de Harvard Business School y New York Business School
para grandes márgenes de ganancia y valor para el accionista.
"Pasta de alto contenido calórico para sus hijos".
¿No?
Uno ama a su mamá exigente.
¿Por qué las mamás exigentes eligen a Jif?
Porque aman más a sus hijos.
El mayor algoritmo para la creación de accionistas de la 2ª Guerra Mundial
en el desarrollo de Google
fue tomar un producto promedio y apelar al corazón de las personas.
Eres una mejor mamá, mejor persona, mejor patriota
si compras este jabón promedio en vez de este jabón promedio.
El algoritmo número uno para el valor del accionista no es la tecnología.
Miren el Forbes 400.
Al margen de la riqueza heredada, y de las finanzas.
La fuente número uno de creación de riqueza:
es apelar a sus órganos reproductivos.
Los Lauder; el hombre más rico de Europa, LVMH.
Números dos y tres: H&M e Inditex.
Se desea apuntar a los órganos más irracionales para el valor del accionista.
Como resultado, estas cuatro compañías: Apple, Amazon, Facebook y Google,
han desarticulado quienes somos.
Dios, amor, consumo, sexo.
La proporción en el enfoque de esas cosas es quién es uno,
y han remodelado quiénes somos en forma de compañías con fines de lucro.
Al final de la Gran Recesión,
la capitalización bursátil de estas compañías era equivalente
al PIB de Níger.
Ahora es equivalente al PIB de India,
habiendo superado al de Rusia y Canadá en 13 y 14.
Solo hay cinco naciones
que tienen un PBI mayor que la capitalización de mercado combinada
de estas cuatro empresas.
Sin embargo, algo está sucediendo.
La conversación hace solo un año fue, ¿qué CEO era más parecido a Jesús?
¿Quién se postulaba para presidente?
Ahora la paciencia se ha acabado.
Todo lo que están haciendo es molestarnos.
Nos preocupa que sean evasores de impuestos.
Walmart, desde la Gran Recesión, ha pagado USD 64 000 millones
en impuestos de sociedades.
Amazon ha pagado 1400.
¿Cómo pagamos a nuestros soldados, bomberos y trabajadores sociales,
si las empresas más exitosas del mundo no pagan su parte proporcional?
Muy fácil.
Eso significa que las empresas menos exitosas tienen que pagar
más que su parte justa.
Alexa, ¿esto es algo bueno?
Esto a pesar de ese hecho
(Risas)
Esto es a pesar del hecho de que
Amazon ha agregado la capitalización del completo mercado de Walmart
a su capitalización del mercado en los últimos 19 meses.
¿De quién es la culpa? Es nuestra culpa.
Elegimos reguladores que no tienen el coraje
de perseguir realmente a estas compañías.
Facebook miente a los reguladores de la UE
y dice: "Sería imposible compartir los datos
entre nuestra plataforma central y nuestra propuesta de adquirir WhatsApp.
Aprueben la fusión".
Aprueban la fusión y luego, ¡se dan cuenta!
Y la UE dice: "Me siento engañada.
Les multamos con USD 120 000 millones".
un 0,6 % del precio de adquisición de USD 19 000 millones.
Si Mark Zuckerberg pudiera contratar una póliza de seguro
de adquisición por un 0,6 %,
¿no lo haría?
Comportamiento anticompetitivo.
Una multa de USD 2500 millones,
USD 3000 millones del flujo de efectivo,
es el 3 % del efectivo en el balance de resultados de Google.
Le decimos a estas compañías: "Lo más inteligente que hay que hacer,
teniendo en mente a los accionistas,
es mentir y hacer trampa".
Emitiendo boletos de estacionamiento de 25 centavos
en un medidor que cuesta USD 100 por hora.
Lo más inteligente es mentir.
¡Destrucción del trabajo!
Amazon solo necesita una persona por dos en Macy's.
Si hacen crecer su negocio USD 20 000 millones este año, que lo harán,
perderemos 53 000 cajeros y empleados.
Esto no es nada inusual;
ha sucedido en toda nuestra economía,
nunca hemos visto empresas tan buenas en eso.
Ese es un estadio de los Yankee lleno de trabajadores.
Es aún peor en los medios.
Si Facebook y Google hacen crecer sus negocios
USD 22 000 millones este año, que lo harán,
perderemos unos 150 000 directores creativos,
planificadores y redactores.
O podemos llenar dos estadios y medio de los Yankee
y decir: "Estás sin trabajo, por cortesía de Amazon".
Obtenemos la mayoría de nuestras noticias por nuestros medios sociales,
y la mayoría de nuestras noticias que provienen de los medios sociales son...
noticias falsas.
(Risas)
No se me permite ser político, usar malas palabras,
o hablar de religión aquí,
así que definitivamente no puedo decir:
"Zuckerberg se ha convertido en la puta de Putin".
Definitivamente no puedo decir eso.
(Risas)
Su defensa:
"Facebook no es una compañía de medios, es una compañía de tecnología".
Uds. crean el contenido original,
pagan ligas deportivas para que les den contenido original,
Uds. reciben publicidad para eso, ¡bum!, son una compañía de medios.
Solo en los últimos días,
Sheryl Sandberg repite esa mentira de que "no somos una compañía de medios".
Facebook ha abrazado abiertamente los márgenes de celebridad
y la influencia de una compañía de medios
sin embargo, parece ser alérgica a la responsabilidad
de una compañía de medios.
Piensen en McDonald's.
Encontramos que el 80 % de su carne es falsa,
y nos está dando encefalitis,
y estamos tomando decisiones terribles
y decimos: "McDonald's, ¡estamos enojados!"
Y dicen: "Esperen, esperen...
no somos un restaurante de comida rápida,
somos una plataforma de comida rápida".
(Risas)
Estas compañías y sus CEOs se envuelven
en un arcoíris rosado de neón y una manta azul
para crear un truco ilusionista de su comportamiento todos los días,
que es más indicativo del engendro de Darth Vader y Ayn Rand.
¿Por qué? Porque nosotros, como progresistas, somos buenos pero débiles.
Si Sheryl Sandberg hubiera escrito un libro sobre derechos de armas
o sobre el movimiento pro-vida,
¿estarían volando Sheryl a Cannes?
No.
Y no dudo de sus valores progresistas,
pero se basa en el valor para el accionista,
porque nosotros como progresistas somos vistos como débiles.
Son muy buenos, ¿recuerdan Microsoft?
No parecían tan agradables,
y los reguladores intervinieron mucho antes que los reguladores actuales,
que nunca intervendrían a esas personas lindas y agradables.
Estoy a punto de tomar un avión esta noche,
y tendré a un tipo llamado Roy de la TSA que me molesta.
Si sospechan que tengo influencia de alcohol camino a casa,
me pueden sacar sangre.
¡Pero esperen! No toquen el iPhone,
es sagrado.
Esta es nuestra nueva cruz.
No debería ser el iPhone X,
debería llamarse "iPhone Cruz".
Tenemos nuestra religión, se llama Apple.
Nuestro Jesucristo es Steve Jobs,
y hemos decidido que esto es más santo que nuestra persona, nuestra casa
o nuestra computadora.
Estamos totalmente descontrolados
con la gran idolatría de la innovación y de la juventud.
Ya no adoramos en el altar
la bondad,
sino de innovación y personas que crean valor para los accionistas.
Amazon se ha vuelto tan poderosa en el mercado,
que puede llevar a cabo trucos mentales Jedi.
Puede comenzar a dañar otras industrias con solo mirarlas.
Nike anuncia que distribuyen en Amazon, sus acciones aumentan,
todas las demás acciones de calzado caen.
Al subir las acciones de Amazon, el resto de las acciones minoristas bajan,
porque suponen que lo que es bueno para Amazon es malo para el resto.
Redujeron el costo del salmón al 33 % al adquirir Whole Foods.
Entre el momento en que anunciaron la adquisición de Whole Foods
y cuando se cerró,
Kroger, el mayor supermercado online de EE.UU.
arrojó un tercio de sus resultados,
porque Amazon compró un supermercado de un undécimo del tamaño de Kroger.
Tuve mucha suerte.
Predije la adquisición de Whole Foods por Amazon
la semana antes de que sucediera.
Este soy yo jactándome. Lo dije públicamente en los medios.
Esta fue la adquisición más grande en su historia,
nunca habían hecho una adquisición de más de mil millones,
y la gente preguntó: "¿Cómo lo supiste?"
Así que expondré ante esta audiencia tan impresionante el secreto.
¿Cómo lo sé?
Les diré cómo lo supe.
Llamo la atención de Alexa todo el día
y trato de descubrir qué está pasando.
(Scott Galloway) Alexa, compra leche entera.
(Alexa) No pude encontrar nada para la leche entera,
así que agregué leche entera a tu lista de compras.
SG: Entonces pregunté,
(SG) Alexa, compra alimentos orgánicos.
(Alexa) El resultado de búsqueda es superior para comida orgánica.
Plum Organics es comida para bebés, bananas y calabaza,
12 paquetes de 100 gr cada uno.
Son USD 15 en total.
¿Te gustaría comprarlo?
SG: Y luego, como sucede a menudo a mi edad,
me confundí.
(SG) Alexa, compra alimentos integrales.
(Alexa) Compré acciones excedentes de Whole Foods Incorporated
a USD 42 por acción.
He cargado 13 700 millones en su tarjeta American Express.
(Risas)
SG: Pensé que sería más divertido.
Hemos personificado estas compañías,
al igual que cuando uno está enojado por cada pequeña cosa que hace
en su vida y sus relaciones,
hay que preguntarse:
"¿Qué pasa aquí? ¿Por qué estamos tan decepcionados con la tecnología?"
Creo que es porque la proporción del 1 % de búsqueda
del valor para el accionista
y el 99 % de la mejora de la humanidad
que solía dar esa tecnología
se ha invertido y ahora
nos enfocamos solo en el valor para los accionistas en lugar de la humanidad.
Cien mil personas se reunieron para el Proyecto Manhattan
y literalmente salvó al mundo.
La tecnología salvó al mundo.
Mi madre era una judía de cuatro años que vivía en Londres al inicio de la guerra.
Si no hubiésemos ganado la carrera hacia la división del átomo,
¿ella habría sobrevivido?
No es probable.
Veinticinco años después,
el logro más impresionante, posiblemente, en toda la humanidad:
poner a un hombre en la luna
430 000 canadienses, británicos y estadounidenses se reunieron,
de nuevo, con tecnología muy básica,
y llevaron a un hombre a la luna.
Ahora tenemos los 700 000 mejores y más brillantes,
y estos son los mejores y más brillantes de los cuatro cantos de la tierra.
Están jugando literalmente con láser en relación con las hondas,
en relación con la pistola de agua.
Tienen el PIB de India para trabajar en ello.
Y después de estudiar estas compañías durante 10 años,
sé cuál es su misión.
¿Es organizar la información del mundo?
¿Es conectarnos?
¿Es crear un mayor compromiso humano?
No lo es.
Sé por qué los hemos reunido.
Sé que la mayor colección de capital de CI y creatividad,
tiene como única misión
vender otro jodido Nissan.
Mi nombre es Scott Galloway, enseño en NYU y aprecio su tiempo.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Sin planearlo,
me suscitaste algunas preguntas, Scott.
(Risas)
Esa fue una diatriba espectacular.
SG: ¿Es esto como Letterman?
Cuando lo haces bien, ¿él te llama al sofá?
CA: No, no, vas al corazón de la conversación en este momento.
Todos saben que después de años de adorar a Silicon Valley,
de repente, se acabó la paciencia
de manera monumental.
Algunas personas aquí sentirán como si estuvieras aumentando la presión,
estás pateando a los niños que ya han sido pateados de todos modos.
¿No sientes empatía por ellos?
SG: Ninguna en absoluto.
Mira, este es el problema:
no es su culpa, es nuestra culpa.
Son compañías con fines de lucro.
No les preocupa la condición de nuestras almas.
No nos van a cuidar cuando seamos mayores.
Hemos creado una sociedad que valora el valor para los accionistas sobre todo,
y están haciendo lo que se supone que deben hacer.
Pero tenemos que elegir personas,
y tenemos que obligarnos a forzarlos,
a que estén sujetos al mismo escrutinio
que el resto de los negocios, punto.
CA: Hay otra narrativa posible
y que es igualmente consistente con los hechos,
de que realmente hay buenas intenciones en gran parte del liderazgo.
No digo todos, necesariamente,
muchos de los empleados.
Todos conocemos a personas que trabajan en esas empresas,
y todavía son bastante convincentes de cuál es su misión:
Y la narrativa alternativa es que ha habido
consecuencias no deseadas,
que las tecnologías que estamos desencadenando,
los algoritmos que intentamos personalizar en Internet, por ejemplo,
resultaron en efectos extraños, como los filtros burbuja
que no esperábamos;
y se hicieron vulnerables a cosas raras como
hackers rusos que crean cuentas
y hacen cosas que no esperábamos.
¿No es posible aquí la consecuencia involuntaria?
SG: No creo.
Estoy bastante seguro, estadísticamente,
no son menos ni mejores personas que cualquier otra organización
con 100 000 o más personas.
No creo que sean malas personas.
De hecho, diría que
hay mucho liderazgo decente y de mentalidad cívica.
Pero este es el problema:
cuando controlas el 90 % de los puntos de las acciones de un mercado,
que es más grande que todo el mercado publicitario de cualquier nación,
y se te recompensa e intentas desarrollar seguridad económica
para ti y las familias de tus empleados,
para aumentar esa cuota de mercado,
no puedes evitar aprovechar toda la potencia a tu disposición.
Y esa es la base de la regulación,
y es la base de la perogrullada a lo largo de la historia:
el poder corrompe.
No son malas personas;
hemos dejado que estén fuera de control.
CA: ¿Entonces tal vez el caso es un poco exagerado?
Sé al menos un poco...
Larry Page, por ejemplo, Jeff Bezos...
realmente no creo que se despierten pensando:
"Tengo que vender un maldito Nissan".
No creo que ellos piensen eso.
Creo que tratan de construir algo genial y, probablemente,
en momentos de reflexión,
están horrorizados por algunas cosas que han sucedido.
Y, ¿hay una forma diferente de encarar esto?
¿De decir que cuando tu modelo se anuncia,
hay peligros que tienes que asumir más explícitamente?
SG: Creo que es muy difícil establecer una organización como lo hacemos,
buscar el valor para los accionistas por encima de todo.
No son organizaciones sin fines de lucro.
La razón por la que las personas trabajan allí es porque quieren crear
seguridad económica para ellos y sus familias,
principalmente por eso.
Y cuando llegas a controlar tanto poder económico,
usas todas las armas a tu disposición.
No creo que sean malas personas,
pero creo que el papel del gobierno y nuestro papel como consumidores
y como personas que elegimos a nuestros funcionarios
es asegurarnos de que haya algunos controles aquí.
Y les hemos dado todos los pases
porque los encontramos simplemente fascinantes.
CA: Scott, muy elocuente y espectacularmente planteado.
Mark Zuckerberg, Jeff Bezos, Larry Page, Tim Cook, si están mirando,
pueden venir y hacer el contraargumento también.
Scott, muchas gracias.
SG: Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)